thomas tu te regarder le tweet de rachid
un internaute qui a fait car alger une
polémique qui a fait beaucoup parler
zalando ça se voit qu'ils ont cherché le
boss dans ce tee shirt tout ça pour
qu'on parle de ça se voit trop un tee
shirt vendu sur le site en ligne
à l'endos a fait un énorme buzz regarder
où il explique tout ça en vidéo et voici
une nouvelle polémique qui touche un
site de e-commerce suite à la
publication d'un article de mode jugés
racistes par de nombreux internautes
c'est au tour de la marque à l'endos de
faire parler d'elle pour ce que beaucoup
considèrent comme un dérapage raciste en
question un t-shirt repéré par un
consommateur suisse sur lequel on peut
apercevoir la main d'un individu en
train de se noyer
la main et en noir et le mannequin
portant le t-shirt étant lui aussi noir
les internautes y ont vu un lien morbide
à l'actualité et aux migrants qui se
noient chaque jour en mer en tentant de
fuir leur pays
une interprétation personnelle que la
marque a tout de suite tenté d'inverser
en expliquant qu'il n'était évidemment
pas question de s'armer face au tollé
suscité par le vêtement la marque a
décidé de le retirer de la vente et a
tenu à s'excuser dans un communiqué une
chose est sûre en tous les cas pour les
fabricants les sites de e-commerce en
mieux vaut y réfléchir à deux fois avant
de mettre un article en vente
oui valérie bénaïm mais pardon mais à
chaque fois ils nous font le coup on
s'est pas rendu compte de ce qu'on a
fait ils nous prennent vraiment pour des
crétins que ce soit zalando où les
autres ce qu'ils nous prennent pour des
bars dont vous pensez qu'ils nous
prennent pour des râles ou fip
non mais c'est pas la première fois
qu'ils aident qui a des choses qui sont
comme ça et que tout d'un coup on retire
de la vente en disant oh mon dieu je
n'avais pas vu pardonnez moi lors de la
dernière fois ci il évoque un acte et
volonté non mais vous plaisantez là vous
savez ce qu'ils ont donné comme mot
comme réponse à ça sur l'imprimé sur le
tee shirt n'est pas lié à la crise
actuelle
le motif peut être considéré comme un
commentaire sur le réchauffement de la
planète et l'accélération de l'élévation
du niveau de la mer il se fout de la
gueule de qui je sais que vous cyril
vous êtes un homme généreux que vous
pardonner facilement oui mais moi j'ai
beaucoup de mal
et franchement ça fait plein de fois que
des grandes marques de mode maintenant
eu des sites d'achat ils se foutent de
notre gueule et moi ce que je vais faire
je vais vous dire je vais les boycotter
parce qu'ils font exprès c'est du
racisme c'est contre les migrants à
chaque fois ça voulons battre parce que
cindy vous le savez les faux médicaments
il sombre et assez bête pourquoi suis je
veux pas que noir je ne peux pas croire
mais franchement ici là vous voyez le
mal partout après ouais je vois que le
t-shirt déjà les idées d'où il faut pas
se mentir voilà c'est ça après s'ils ont
fait ça s'est vraiment bien alors à
l'asco faut arrêter jamais arrêté je
trouve que j'ai complètement délirant un
règne du patio et tu n'as aucune preuve
donc arrêter l'histoire de boycott à
bangkok qui ne concerne que toi le fait
de dire qu'ils ont fait exprès de faire
ça tu n'en sais rien donc arrêtent de
jeter des anathèmes comme ça et de deux
cadets même si c'était un rapport avec
les migrants est-ce qu'il peut pas
considérer que c'est au contraire une
alerte pour une prise de conscience
générale du problème la toiture me côté
a motivé la main tendue si elles ces
personnes n'ont pas tu dis il ya un
drame qui se passe et personne n'en
parle l'ail et un t-shirt qui prêtait
c'est une alerte politique où les gens
disent et dont les caisses que
visiblement ça porte à controverse
on va passer vite là tu le t-shirt mais
je suis encore plus choquée par un
migrant qui se noie et ça j'aurais
tellement aimé qui est justement un
raz-de-marée et que tout le monde se
révolte contre tous les migrants qui se
noie plus qu'un tissu de mulets caroline
super véloce et ensuite ça a créé la
polémique
c'est quand même des gens qui sont
intéressés que par le profit qu'ils vont
pas faire exprès de créer une polémique
qui va salir la marque pour ensuite se
dire bat finalement à le retirer
c'est absolument pas un migrant qui se
noie faut arrêter aussi dit m alors que
vous dire après dix mois je pensais très
mal awad lors pas fait ça mais après je
peux me tromper c'est vraiment se tirer
une balle dans le pied